I just want to tell you something up
front which is I started using
Mathematica 2.2 and 1994 and I was blown
away I thought it was awesome I was
using it as an undergraduate and by
about 2000 or so it had gotten so good
at doing integrals that I had this uh
rule of thumb that was if Mathematica
couldn't do it I can't unless I had a
library in probably hours and a lot of
luck so yes no I think it's it's it's
past humans it cost humans a while ago
um welcome back to mlst so um in an era
of technology and Innovation few
individuals have left as indelible a
mark on the fabric of modern science as
our esteemed guest Dr Stephen Wolfram Dr
Wolfram is a renowned polymath who has
left significant contributions to the
fields of physics Computer Science and
Mathematics a prodigious young man too a
Wolfram earned a PhD in theoretical
physics from the California Institute of
Technology by the age of 20. and and he
became the youngest recipient of the
prestigious MacArthur fellowship at the
age of 21.
wolfram's groundbreaking computational
tool Mathematica was launched in 1988
and has become a Cornerstone for
researchers and innovators worldwide and
in 2002 he published A New Kind of
Science a paradigm shifting work which
explored the foundations of science
through the lens of computational
systems in 2009 Wolfram created Wolfram
Alpha a computational knowledge engine
utilized by millions of users worldwide
and his current focus is on the Wolfram
language which is a powerful programming
language designed to democratize access
to cutting-edge technology wolfram's
numerous accolades include honorary
doctorates and fellowships from
prestigious institutions and as an
influential thinker Dr Wolfram has
dedicated his life to unraveling the
mysteries of the universe and making
computation accessible to all as a
Trailblazer in the world of science and
technology Dr Wolfram has dedicated his
life to unraveling the mysteries of the
universe and placing the power of
computation in the hands of the masses
so we invite you to join us on this
captivating Journey Through the mind of
one of the most influential thinkers of
our time and Dr Wolfram has just dropped
a new book on chat GPT which I had the
pleasure of reading earlier and I highly
recommend you buy it and uh actually
even more exciting than that we've got
the scoop on this Dr Wolfram has just
announced an integration with chat GPT
there's now a plugins feature and you
can you can interrogate Wolfram Alpha
from chatgpt but we'll get on to that in
just a second but just to finish the
introduction sit back folks relax
prepare to have your curiosity peaked
and your horizons broadened as we embark
on this adventure into the extraordinary
realm of Dr Stephen Wolfram Dr Wolfram
welcome to mlst thank you
um why don't we start with the most
exciting bit which is this big
announcement why don't you tell us about
that first
yeah well so as of today chat GPT can
sort of get computational superpowers by
calling on Wolfram Alpha and Wolfram
language uh through its plug-in
mechanism and uh the you know chat gbt
is a large language model which has kind
of gone through the web and lots of
books and so on and it is piecing
together things by sort of seeing what a
reasonable piece of continuing text
would be and it's amazing how far that
gets and we'll we'll perhaps talk a
little bit later about why I think it
gets as far as it does but the thing it
isn't able to do is actually do sort of
serious computation it is just saying
let me continue this text based on
things that I've seen on the web and and
things that sort of seem reasonable
based on the structure of language as
humans have written it but when it comes
to actually Computing things that's just
not something a neural net like it does
but we've been building for a long time
now uh well Wilson language what's talk
about that probably a bunch later our
sort of computational language to
represent the world in a sort of precise
computational way and well from alpha
the kind of consumer version of that
that takes natural language input
converts that to welcome language to
precise computational language and then
does computations and very conveniently
Chachi PT in a sense talks natural
language too so that provides a kind of
immediate Bridge through the Wolfram
Alpha natural language understanding
system so that chat GPT when it wants to
actually do a serious computation can
now reach out through or from alpha or
directly to open language to our whole
technology stack to get those
computations done and obviously another
piece of what we've done is to get sort
of computable curated data about the
world and sort of implement the models
and methods and algorithms and so on
that are needed to to sort of compute
expert level answers to things and so
now chat GPT has access to all of those
kinds of tools I think it's kind of an
exciting moment in kind of a merger of
two different sort of approaches to kind
of the problem of AI the sort of
statistical approach of just sort of see
what's out there and kind of learn from
that and the kind of symbolic approach
of see what you can actually compute I
would say that the things we've done I
don't haven't really viewed as being
quote AI as such it's more the the
deeper story of computation but now
we've got this kind of merger of these
two approaches uh that just released
about an hour ago now
yeah it's amazing I don't think anyone
would have seen this coming even five
years ago when language models started
coming onto the scene that they might be
used as a tool to take a natural
language intelligible input and
transform it into a representation that
can be used on a downstream system it's
absolutely amazing but why don't we go
on a bit of an intellectual Journey
because I was very interested reading
reading your book and I wondered whether
you could um we'll just start with how
the language models work and kind of
build from there philosophically and I
mean philosophically and deeply because
our audience are actually experts on on
deep learning I wondered if you could
talk about how language models work from
from your kind of abstract deep
understanding what the reasons are for
their success and um you said in the
book that Computing the probability of
even 10 tuples of language would require
more data than there are atoms in the
universe
um which is very interesting so language
models are clearly doing some kind of
clever interpolation and most
importantly the thing that I'm very
interested in is what does it mean to
understand
do you think there are language encodes
enough representational Fidelity to
afford a useful semantic mapping to
grounded reality or you know to what
most people would understand in the
world and I'm sure you're aware of two
major strands of thought in the
philosophy of meaning which is to say
meaning as reference and meaning as use
so perhaps you could bring that into
your answer as well well okay so so what
does it mean to understand something
one of the things when we built wolf
malfur in 2009 people have been trying
to make you know natural language
understanding systems for a long time
the problem that they always had which I
didn't realize until after the fact I
have to say was that it wasn't clear
what to understand actually means you
have this computer it's doing it what
it's doing but what does it mean to
understand well we had a very definite
definition of understanding it was take
the natural language and convert it to
our computational language from which a
computation can be done we had a target
for understanding we had something which
was kind of the the the ultimate
representation from which we could do
all these things with computation and so
on and that was our operational
definition of understanding now when you
ask a question like I think it becomes a
much muddier question when you say what
does a language model understand for me
sort of the the sort of the gold
standard of understanding is you can
convert it to a computational language
you can compute all sorts of things
about about it you can you can kind of
uh you can figure out from it anything
that can be figured out from from that
as from that sort of thing that is
represented in this precise ways
computational language I think the thing
that I've sort of realized uh so I've
been interested in a long for a long
time and kind of how do you represent
things in the world in a sort of formal
computational way that's been the whole
story of building uh I wasn't language
computational language but
the I've also been sort of interested
I've been curious for a long time how do
you take kind of everyday discourse and
convert it also to something
computational you know in our in modern
language for example if well let's say I
say I want to eat a piece of chocolate
Okay in modern language we have a lovely
representation of pieces of chocolate we
know about all kinds of different kinds
of chocolate we can characterize the
size Etc et cetera et cetera we haven't
had a characterization of the I want to
eat part of that sentence but it is
something I've long thought should be
possible to represent in a kind of
formal computational way I think what
chat GPT is showing us is that yes it
really is possible to think about
language and kind of a and the things we
represent by language in a quite
structured way so I mean the way I like
to see it is what what charging PT has
discovered regularities in language so
first first thing just to comment on
this question of you know when it wants
to make a continuation of a piece of
text
you know if it's just if it's just a
single word it might be able to go out
on the web and just look at the Corpus
and figure out the probability based on
other occurrences of the previous words
but by the time as you were mentioning
by the time it's any substantial number
of words there's no way it can have sort
of you know statistical data to just
work out the probability from that so it
has to have a model and one thing that's
really interesting about neural Nets is
when you have a model there are there's
no Obvious definition of a right answer
you know it could be there could be but
the our operational definition of a
right answer is it sounds right to a
human so the thing that's really
interesting about neural Nets is they do
this modeling they do this continuation
they do this extension beyond the merely
statistical so to speak by in a way that
corresponds to what we humans expect
perhaps that isn't surprising because
neural Nets are architecturally quite
similar to brains and you know neural
Nets as they exist in chat gbt are
remarkably similar to the kind of
original idealization invented by
McCulloch and Pitts in the 1940s but
they're kind of the fact that what the
continuation the particular model that
Chachi BT or a neural net is using is
something that corresponds to what we
humans expect that's the thing that's
interesting you know if we were to
imagine the aliens or the octopuses or
whatever else it's not obvious that the
thing that would be a reasonable
continuation for us would also be a
reasonable continuation for them but
that's a feature that happens to exist
that we've discovered exists for these
idealized neural Nets that we use in
things like chat GPT now the question
then is well what you know when we see
sort of uh what did it discover about
language that allows it to make that
model what what's in that model it could
be the case that that model is just
something that we humans will never
understand it's something that's kind of
a the insides of an automated theorem
proving system or something that a kind
of a lot of structure or the insides of
a machine Learning System where we look
at it and we say well that's interesting
it works nicely it picked out some
features we don't understand what the
features are it's not something it's
beyond sort of human understanding but
it's interesting to try to see can we
get some kind of narrative understanding
what's happening and I think the things
the two things that we know about
language one is that it has a definite
syntactic grammar you know we know nouns
and verbs go in the places they go it's
one thing we know the other thing we
know is that logic Works in language I
mean when logic was originally invented
by Aristotle and so on back in Antiquity
you know I've got my imagination of what
Aristotle did is something much like a
machine Learning System would do he
looked at lots of examples of rhetoric
and he said what are some patterns of
how language Works in these pieces of
rhetoric that are sort of making
arguments and so on what are the
patterns of language that successfully
make arguments and from that he
extracted your syllogistic logic the you
know all men and Mortal Socrates a man
therefore Socrates is a mortal type
thing those those kinds of structures he
he extracted from language this kind of
uh superstructure that is that is the
kind of uh abstract logic and and from
that much later in the 1800s you know
Bool and people made it more
mathematical made a kind of tower out of
logic that goes beyond what is what is
represented directly in language but I
think what we're seeing in in tragedy PT
is is it sort of discovered and we don't
yet know what these precise patterns are
but it's discovered kind of a semantic
grammar of language and I think what the
way we can think about what it's doing
is it is putting together essentially
these puzzle pieces just like when you
make us a syntactic grammar of language
you're defining these are the kind of
trees and so on that you can put
together these are the parse trees you
can put together to form a a
syntactically reasonable sentence well
it's finding the things that will allow
you to put together a semantically
reasonable sentence essay whatever else
and so I think that's kind of that's my
sort of uh understanding of what it's
doing now if you say is there an
underlying sort of understanding that it
has again I I consider that a very
floppy question I consider that the the
sort of the really well-grounded version
of that question is can we turn it into
something computational from which we
can then use a a precise formal system
to go and and figure out things from it
or even even maybe the next step might
be can we once we had that structure and
we can perform computation on it through
Wolfram Alpha for example can we then
turn around and turn that into action
that we can take into the world that has
you know certain desired effects and
this is what I wanted to ask you is okay
Bing came along and sort of provided
some computation to um GPT but very
restricted you know restricted to
searching and and that sort of thing
Wolfram Alpha now finally gives it the
power of full complete Turing complete
anything goes you know kind of
calculation if we now allow it to
feedback on itself so this this system
Chad gbt plus plus Wolfram Alpha if it's
now able to say put information back
into the info sphere send out tweets put
stuff on a web page that can then come
back through you know the GPT you know
engine which as you say we may never
understand it it may just always be kind
of a black box to us but it can add its
little bit of natural language magic and
complete the circle we now have almost
this massive turing machine that has
these hybrid components to it you know
is this potentially the first step
towards artificial general intelligence
or are there still some missing
ingredients
well I think that the thing you the
picture you paint one of the points that
I think you're making is in a sense
Church EBT on its own is reconstituting
what US humans have already written on
the web and in books and things like
that it's putting it together in novel
ways but it's sort of the same pieces
it's not creating new knowledge as soon
as you have actual computation in the
loop and what I would talk about as as
irreducible computation you can build
what amounts to new knowledge and so yes
it surely is the case that you know you
ask chat TPT plus well from some some
question it goes off it it creates a
piece of language code or something it
goes and and runs somewhere it finds new
knowledge it could then if it wanted to
it could tweak that new knowledge and
then that new knowledge could get
incorporated into the kind of uh into
the Corpus of knowledge a corpus of
language that can be used by chat gbt
and so on so yes I think that the the
thing that
is uh you know the way to perhaps think
about this is uh in the end you know
there's sort of a whole separate
civilization of the AIS that is is in
the process of developing I mean we
already see that a whole bunch in uh in
the things that operate on on the web
today and so on but I think we'll see
we'll see an increasing amount of that
going forward and it's kind of uh you
know the way I I've been curious
thinking about sort of so what's going
to happen to all of us and the you know
when the civilization of the AIS is is
there and what will it feel like to be
in a world where a lot of what happens
is happening in kind of the AI sphere
and not in the human sphere already a
lot of that is happening I mean already
a lot of things that you know we're
presented with on on the web and things
like that come out of AI like processors
not out of some kind of uh human
decision making but I think you know the
way I the the analogy is is really our
experience of the natural world the
natural world is full of what I think of
as computational processes going on that
that are ones that we don't
intrinsically understand the natural
world just does what it does we have
found a way to exist sort of to coexist
with the natural world we've had the
convenient feature that we've had a few
billion years of biological evolution to
figure out how to do that it's a little
bit of a different situation with the
the kind of uh with with AI although we
have the the perhaps advantage that AIS
are right now things which are created
as a sort of uh as a as a result of the
things that the Corpus of of material
that we've put on the web I mean I think
the thing to understand about what's
happening with computation and Ai and so
on is computation is a very broad kind
of thing you can you know if you just
pick a program at random this is
something I've been uh very much
involved in over over the decades
actually is asking if you take a very
simple program like a cellular automaton
program or sharing machine for that
matter and you just say I'm going to
pick the rules for this thing let's say
at random and they're tiny rules let's
say just you're know 405 rules six rules
whatever and then you say well what does
the system do you might say based on our
experience with engineering and so on oh
it won't do anything interesting and
complicated because it's such a simple
set of rules that turns out not to be
true that's something I discovered in
the 1980s to my great surprise it took
me a number of years to kind of come to
terms with that discovery that even
extremely simple rules are capable of
generating extremely complicated
Behavior that's a phenomenon of the
computational universe that we're not
particularly used to from our experience
in engineering because in engineering we
usually we want to do things where we
can foresee the output but so what
happens is in the computational universe
kind of there's immensely complex things
that can be produced even with very
simple programs the question is are
those things things that we humans in a
sense care about are they things for
which we humans which we humans would
talk about in the usual things that we
want to do and so I think this idea that
of sort of creativity computational
creativity yes there's an infinite
supply of computational creativity the
challenges of those things that are
created which are ones that we humans
sort of care about which are ones where
in the development of our civilization
our natural language things like this
we've actually got to the point where we
where we think about those kinds of
things uh you know there are plenty of
examples in in history of I don't know
phenomena and physics where you know who
cared about liquid crystals until we
realized that we could make displays out
of them things like this it's sort of
what becomes something about which we
humans kind of care and this sort of
there's a there's as I say an infinite
supply of kind of computational
creativity out there which is certainly
is now accessible for example to chat
GPT but if it goes off and starts
running simple programs and produces all
sorts of complicated output people will
say well that's nice but but you know
it's until until we get to the point
where we have kind of a a human
narrative that kind of encompasses the
kinds of things that are going on there
until we have a reason to care it's just
out there in the computational universe
not something pulled into kind of the
human sphere
I would love to explore this concept of
creativity a little bit I mean first of
all reading your book was
um it was incredible it opened up the
whole world of emergence to me and in a
sense you can think of um a large
language model as being a dynamical
system but it's sclerotic in the sense
that it's been trained and now it's
frozen and something I was thinking
about earlier was the irony that we
almost never need to train it ever again
because now we can prompt it on how to
use Wolfram and how to create this
neurosymbolic architectures and it's
almost like we don't need to change it
anymore but then if you look at um the
representations it's learned and the way
that um our cognitive categories emerge
over time these are things that are
baked into the language model but the
language models aren't very good at
learning new things that continual
learning and this kind of brings us to
this semantic grammar thing you know I
just wondered what your thoughts were on
the underlying model of the world that a
semantic grammar assumes because when
we're talking about cognitive categories
having it fixed isn't necessary really
what we want
right interesting point so you know one
of the things that in a sense I find you
know I'm just sort of coming to terms
with it is in a sense you know Church
EBT and large language models in general
are as you say taking a snapshot of the
world as we humans have created it and
they're just saying okay this is now the
standard you know every essay should now
be written this way because this is the
average of What the world has produced
so far and it's kind of a funny time
it's sort of a a standards moment for a
lot of kinds of knowledge work and so on
and it's a little bit of a strange thing
because it's kind of it now becomes it's
just like you know in the past there
were probably no doubt you know all
sorts of creative ways I don't know
people might have written things by hand
or done this or that and then we have
you know the fixed idea of it's a font
and everybody gets to you know set the
have the thing look the same way so
we've now done that for a large chunk of
kind of knowledge work and the question
of sort of how we of how we how we still
keep doing new things that's an
interesting question and I think that uh
you know computation is the is the giant
escape valve so to speak because it
allows us to do huge numbers of new
things the issue is does our
understanding kind of follow along with
the actual sort of ability of
computation to to kind of create the
news so to speak and I think that's a
those are those are really interesting
questions you know I think the thing to
understand
uh kind of if we think about the sort of
computational Universe of all
possibilities this is something you know
I've been last few years we've had these
big breakthroughs that uh I didn't think
would happen in my lifetime but I'm
really happy that they have with uh
thinking about fundamental physics and
computational terms and that's led to
this kind of big idea of this thing we
call the rouliad which is kind of the
entangled limit of all possible
computations imagine you start all
possible Turing machines with all
possible initial types you start them
all off together and you sort of Simply
look at what states those things produce
so there might be two touring machines
that produce different states and then
later on those States will be will
converge because they'll end up being
the same and you get this this kind of
giant structure and one of the things
that's sort of a a big result is we
think that giant structure is kind of
the thing that's underneath all of
physics and all of mathematics and kind
of our experience of the physical world
is our we are embedded within this rule
ad and our experience of the physical
world is taking some slice of that
rouliad experiencing kind of the set of
all possible computations in a
particular slice that corresponds to the
ways that we kind of that our sensory
data work and that our minds work and I
mean just to just to say one sort of
science point the the big result I
suppose is that if you put only a small
set of constraints on the way that we
observe what's happening in the rouliad
actually really two constraints one is
that we are computationally bounded
we're Limited in the computations we can
do the other constraint is we believe
that we are persistent in time even
though at every moment we get made from
different atoms of space we have the
belief and the experience that there's a
thing that we that we persist Through
Time those two constraints alone are
enough to basically tell you that the
slice of the rouliad that we observe
will satisfy physics as we know it in
fact specifically the three three big
theories of 20th century physics general
relativity the theory of gravity quantum
mechanics and the statistical mechanics
to second law of Thermodynamics and so
on the the amazing thing that's become
clear from stuff we've done last couple
of years is that all three of those
kinds of features of physics as we
experience it are a consequence of us
being observers of the kind we are
observing this rouliad of all possible
computational processes so that's sort
of a a big picture version of so the
physics side of things but that leads
one to this view that sort of Minds
experience the rouyard experience this
sort of entangled limit of all possible
computations it's like we are at a
particular place in the rouliad
experiencing sort of the world in this
particular way just as we're at a
particular place in physical space
experiencing the world with respect to
that place in physical space and so you
think about sort of different Minds as
being different points at different
points in the rouliad so so different
human Minds might be quite close in the
to really add kind of the the animals
might be a bit further away the AIS are
somewhere in the rouliad and what does
it mean when we sort of make progress in
making new paradigms about thinking
about things the way I see it is it's
kind of a an expansion in rural space we
are we are able to Encompass more ways
of thinking about the world than we
could before that's sort of the the
advance of paradigms the increase of
abstraction in in fields like like
mathematics or science or whatever else
and and sort of we're sort of gradually
expanding in rural space able to
Encompass more kinds of ways of looking
at this kind of ultimate computational
structure so I think that the this kind
of um
the thing that that we see as we you
know the the the sort of the growth of
our uh kind of well uh sort of the the
intellectual history of our civilization
can be thought of as this kind of
gradual colonization of rule space and
that that's the and it's something that
seems to happen quite gradually it's not
you know you can easily just sort of
pick a random program and jump to an
arbitrary place in real space the
problem is that there won't be much
human that you can say about it it will
be just it's a program it runs uh it
looks uh but we we don't have a a way of
kind of describing what's going on I
think that's sort of the the limiting
factor and I think what will be
interesting to see is you know can we
can we kind of go on expanding okay
we've got our large language models
which are trained from the way the world
is today
can they tell us oh there's this New
Concept that's really worthwhile can we
deduce from sort of the the
computational world and the world of
large language models and so on there's
this obvious concept that you humans
should be learning about you know this
is a Direction that's worth going in you
know there's an analogy of this I happen
to have made a big study of of the
foundations of mathematics you know in
mathematics it's very easy given an
axiom system for some some area of
mathematics for example to just
enumerate all the possible theorems of
of a reason principle at least to
let's say logic or geometry whatever
else you get this giant entangled limit
of all these possible theorems the
question is which ones have we humans
chosen to actually talk about there's a
there's sort of infinite number of
possible theorems but there's only sort
of an infinite space of possibilities
but only some places have we chosen to
sort of colonize and and describe and so
sort of the you can think of the kind of
the history of mathematics as being
following these particular paths in kind
of meta mathematical space of of all the
possible things that one could be
thinking about all the possible theorems
one could be one could be uh considering
and so I think it's sort of this
interesting thing in the in the world in
general what is it that we could be
thinking about about the world that we
aren't thinking about right now give you
an example that
um uh so you know fractal patterns
nested patterns right things that we've
known about you know sort of popularized
to the last I don't know three or four
decades and sort of known about for
about 100 years well actually those
kinds of nested patterns so far as I
know were first invented by a mosaic
layer in Italy in the 1200s early 1200s
made this thing that particular person
died the uh you know the the art of
making that particular nested pattern
disappeared the art historians wrote
about many of the mosaics done by this
family of Mosaic layers they never
mentioned the nested patterns they
talked about you know the birds and
lions and so on but they were completely
blind to this idea of nested patterns
which then in recent times everybody
would see this pattern say oh that's a
fractal pattern
um but uh you know this is the kind of
example of how sort of when you have a
new paradigm for thinking about things
you kind of noticed things you didn't
notice before and a very interesting
question is what things are there in the
world that we have noticed before in my
own life the the sort of the biggest one
that was this phenomenon that I already
mentioned about how simple programs can
lead to extremely complicated Behavior
that's a very fundamental scientific
result that has all kinds of
implications but that's a result which
as I say after I had first done computer
experiments that plainly showed that
result it still took me several years to
kind of realize oh that's a real you
know that's a real thing and when I look
back I realized there were zillions of
examples of this that existed for
hundreds of years where people just
ignored it I mean you know you look at
it yeah yeah I wonder if I could jump in
here because what you're saying is it's
truly fascinating it's the idea that
that these AIS could help us navigate
this impossibly vast you know space of
possible com you know computation the
ruly ad but there's also the other way
around which is us helping them navigate
and as you pointed out in this kind of
wonderful essay back in February you
know what was yeah what is GPT doing and
why does it work you know in this
impossibly vast space they're sort of
total pure chance there's complete
Randomness and at this narrow boundary
between there's really chaos which is
where all the interesting stuff happens
it's where the irreducibly complex
computations are it's where Turing
machines are it's where all this Rich
behavior is kind of on that on that
boundary and it's almost the sliver and
like you said finding the programs in
this vast space that are useful to
humans or do something interesting is
really difficult and and we've kind of
been discovering over time that as you
build systems that are more and more
capable they become harder and harder to
train and you talk about this a lot in
your essay and you're optimistic that
we're going to find ways to to train you
know these ever more capable systems
effectively and efficiently and uh I'm
wondering how you think we're going to
achieve that like what what's going to
be the key to it what Avenues of
research are promising to take us down
that path of navigating the ruly ad
space
well so so first point to make is let me
this notion of computational
irreducibility which I think is really a
pretty core notion that sort of we're
starting to see kind of pop up in a lot
of different a lot of different places
it's an important piece of kind of
intuition about science the question is
this if you have a program you have a
set of rules you know the set of rules
does that immediately tell you what the
consequences of those rules will be in
traditional science well particularly
mathematical science practice sort of
since the 1600s kind of the big thing
people are always excited about is
science lets you predict stuff given
that you know the the equations the
rules by which something works science
will let you say okay this is what's
going to happen sometime in the future
it's it's just once you know the rules
you can predict the future that's been
the kind of paradigmatic idea of that
people have about science for the last
300 years or so what we realized from
thinking about kind of computational
universe computational thinking about
science based on programs rather than on
equations is that isn't always true in
fact it's often not true instead what
can happen is you've got the rules you
run the rules you can explicitly run
them you run them for a billion steps
you see what happens but then you ask
can you jump ahead and say oh I know you
know can you figure out what's going to
happen a billion steps in the future
without having to explicitly run those
steps and the whole point is that you in
general can't do that and the reason you
can't do that well as a principle that I
kind of came up with quite a long time
ago now called the principle of
computational equivalence which gives
you sort of an understanding of why you
can't do that principle of computational
equivalence says that as soon as you see
a system which is not obviously simple
in its Behavior it will tend to be
equivalent in the sophistication of
computations it can do so you know we've
known since the 1920s 1930s that there
are Universal computers there are
systems that are capable of doing
uh that that can you know that can be
programmed to do any computation what
has not been obvious is that that
phenomenon and actually its
generalization are quite ubiquitous it's
a thing that's been sort of interesting
for me is you look at cellular automata
you look at Turing machines you say you
look at you just start enumerating let's
say possible Turing machines the very
smallest ones only do very simple things
as soon as you have a turing machine
with just let's say three colors on its
tape and two states for its head so six
little cases in its rule turns out the
first turing machine that doesn't do
obviously simple things is computation
Universal so that's kind of evidence for
this principle of computational
equivalence that sort of as soon as the
behavior is not obviously simple it will
be equivalent in its computational
sophistication so what does that mean
well when we're trying to predict
something we say we can predict it what
we mean is we with our brain with our
mathematics whatever else we can jump
ahead of it it takes it a billion steps
to figure out what it's going to do do
but we have this clever way of just
saying I know what you're going to do
after a billion steps the fact is once
we know about computational equivalence
we know that won't be possible in
general we know that there will be
computational irreducibility the only
way to figure out what the system is
going to do is effectively to follow
through each step and see what happens
and that's sort of an important
realization in science it's an important
sort of limitation of science coming
from within science it's kind of also a
little bit the explanation for why bugs
are hard to find and things like this
they're always sort of unexpected
consequences there are always things you
couldn't readily foresee from the
underlying rules that you had but I
think that that um
so this this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that is that's kind of
the hard that's hard computation that's
computation you can't reduce in a sense
we should consider ourselves lucky that
there is irreducible computation because
you know we lead Our Lives we do all
these different things it will be really
bad in a sense but one might feel it
would be really bad if somebody could
just say you know okay you don't need to
lead your life I know what the answer is
it's 42 or whatever else there's nothing
sort of achieved by the passage of time
what computational irreducibility tells
one is that there's sort of something
achieved by the passage of time some
some sort of computational achievement
from the passage of time now the so now
the question might be well how does that
relate to things like training of neural
Nets and so on well essentially
computational irreducibility is the
enemy of neural net training because as
soon as there is computational
irreducibility as soon as there's
actually something you have to
explicitly compute you just can't do
this approach of saying well you know
training is about sort of knowing what
will happen you know being able to sort
of explicitly burn in a prediction of
what will happen and that is explicitly
kind of that's that's sort of the
opposite direction from computational
irreducibility so the thing that's
exciting about for example our uh chat
Plus World from effort of today is that
um
that it's a place where we're combining
something capable of doing irreducible
computation with something that is sort
of the the interface to us humans I mean
I kind of view sort of what chat GPT is
doing and a lot of its potential uses as
being kind of a new form of user
interface it's kind of a linguistic user
interface and the way that we've had in
the past kind of you know we have
graphically certificates Etc I mean in a
sense both malfo was I think the first
sort of serious example of a linguistic
user interface on the input side we were
not dealing with the output so we're not
writing essays we're we're just
generating essentially more like a GUI
kind of output a linguistic input so to
speak but now we've got something where
we where this is kind of uh humanizing
uh kind of a lot of things by providing
this kind of linguistic interface and
language seems to be our richest form of
communication and so having that
linguistic interface is very important
in having a richer form of communication
with sort of the computational world but
I think this this question of
you know how do you find the things that
are interesting to us humans well that's
something that I think these neural Nets
are are beginning to actually know a lot
about because they just were trained on
the things we humans produce they in a
sense have a very finely tuned sense of
sort of what the current state of how we
humans think about things is and so if
you say well what did we miss that
becomes a thing that it can potentially
answer you know the the question of uh
and this is something uh uh I've been
curious about and I did some experiments
but they haven't been very successful
yet it's kind of of all possible let's
say mathematical theorems which ones are
ones that a human is likely to consider
interesting we know some other ways to
try and figure that out but to be able
to say okay you know large language
model you just learned all these things
from what humans have cared about and
put on the web now tell us which things
exist in the computational universe but
we haven't yet sort of for given names
to and so on which ones should we give
names to
yes I I wholeheartedly agree that the
gradient of interestingness is very
important but I also want to bring in
the gradient of conceivability just
before I do that I wanted to comment on
you referring to it as a linguistic
interface and I'm glad that you did
because
um it's a it's an interface that that
can be used by many people in many
different situations but the key thing
is that it's about being intelligible
rather than being a conversational
interface but on this notion of
conceivability you said something
fascinating which is that there's this
Mosaic and and it was it was interesting
to people let's say hundreds or even
thousands of years ago and then it and
then it became lost and Nagel's thought
experiment um about the bat is is a
subjective form of conceivability and
Noam Chomsky talks as a nativist about
the domain of things which are
conceivable as a function of the
cognitive prize which are in our brain
so there's this trajectory space of
things which are conceivable and it's
almost like we're cheating by creating
these computational models which can
subject to irreducibility can compute
all of these different things but the
the key question is whether or not we
would recognize something as being
interesting or whether it would be
conceivable even if it were present
right so I think this is the thing
progress is gradual and slow in other
words if you jump to some random place
in the rouliad you pick a random program
you look at it you know when you first
look at it it's like I don't know why I
care about this it's something where you
we have to have a a kind of a I don't
know whether you can call it cognitive
or or intellectual history kind of path
that gets there we don't we don't get to
talk about the you know until we've
we've built sort of the ambient ideas
until we built this kind of intellectual
path
it isn't really it doesn't really work
to just jump to that place it's like I
could make up a word and uh I don't know
I could make up a word for I don't know
let's say look at look at clouds in the
sky and they have all kinds of weird
different shapes and we have a few names
for a few of those shapes right now we
don't have a reason to care about the
particular details of those shapes but
you know I can make up a word for one of
those things but until I can sort of
tell you why we care about that it
becomes something that's very hard to
it's something we're sort of not
connected to I I kind of think it's one
of these things where it is there's sort
of a a a a sense of gradual progress but
you kind of can't it's a it's it's you
can't kind of jump ahead it's kind of
like the computational irreducibility
story actually that you can't kind of
jump to a random place and expect to
have understanding there
well it may be the case too maybe we
don't need to understand it right
because as long as
let's say the the uh AI is producing
structured
Concepts even if we don't understand
those Concepts if they're structured
enough that that uh programs in Wolfram
Alpha can make use of them to produce
actions let's say in the world that are
good for us then we may not even need to
understand
those Concepts at least not yet
um right I think I think this is the
this is the kind of question of you know
once we Define the goals how those goals
get implemented is something that is a
matter of interest for science but it's
not necessarily a matter of relevance
for the people using it and I think this
is the this is the thing which is sort
of an interesting phenomenon in well the
history of computing particularly is
what is it that you're trying to get out
of a computer well you're trying to
achieve certain goals you're trying to
and and this is where you know my sort
of lifelong story of kind of the
programming languages versus the the
full-scale computational language idea
you know the programming languages which
are really talking to computers in terms
that computers intrinsically understand
you know set this um
set up this array you know and uh move
this you know do this Loop you know
change this value from this to this to
this that's that's the sort of the
computer's intrinsic understanding I
think that uh uh you know the thing I've
long been interested in is how do we go
from something that is the way we think
about things how do we make a bridge
between the way we think about things
and what is possible computationally and
the thing that has been my long time
effort is to build our computational
language well from language to be able
to sort of be that bridge between the
way we think about things the things we
think about and what is computationally
possible so I I think the um
this this uh uh this question of of um
uh sort of relating well let's see the
the I think I didn't respond to what you
you would say something interesting and
I think I lost my thread of what what
you were uh what what you were uh what
was it was really um I think
what I'm what I'm trying to find out is
what role human beings you know are
actually going to play in building the
better architectures of tomorrow because
because you made a point in in that
article from February that you know
right now to be honest the the
construction of these architectures is
an art it's really just people do some
trial and error they come up with some
horseshoes or whatever shape you know of
uh of architecture happens to work you
know gpts and that's you know same kind
of category you point out there's no
real science you know behind that and on
the one hand we could defer all that
science to AIS potentially and maybe
we'll never understand the science that
they do to build the next better
versions of themselves but I'm wondering
if you also have any space in your
vision for us developing human
intelligible sciences that can do a
better job of this and if so like what
might they look like and what other
Sciences might they resemble zoology you
know I don't know right so I think the
thing okay so this question of uh uh
sort of so this thing that's going on
inside that's very complicated that's
computationally irreducible what can we
say about it and you know we can still
have something where there's complicated
computations going on they achieve goals
we're interested in we're happy we're
done we can then go in as you as you
point out and ask what's the science of
what's Happening inside in a sense the
Neuroscience has been that story of we
know what we humans do you know how does
we know something about how the
microscopic brain uh you know works and
you know neuron firings and so on we
don't have an Intermediate Language of
Neuroscience that is kind of the thing
that is above the level of individual
neuron firings and below the level of
psychology basically and I think that
that's um the question of can you find
that and when can you find that it's a
very interesting question I think one of
the things that is a science point that
when you have computational
irreducibility one of of the necessary
consequences of computational
irreducibility is within a computational
irreducible system that will always be
an infinite number of specific little
pieces of computational reusability that
you can find in other words even though
you can't say everything there are lots
of little pieces that little things you
can say in a sense that's why you know
if we take it at a more General level if
you say well what inventions can we make
given the physical world which has
computational irreducibility what things
can we predict what things can we invent
which have foreseeable behavior and so
on and the answer is there will be there
will be an infinite collection of these
things we'll never run out of inventions
little pieces of computational
reducibility that we can find in this
ultimately computational irreducible
Universe in which we live so in a sense
we're always we're always finding these
little jumps little pieces of
computational reducibility and those
pieces of computational reducibility may
be big enough that we can kind of live
in them you know the fact that we
believe space is continuous that is a
feature of a slice of computational
reducibility from the underlying
computational irreducibility of this
complicated as you know the the way
we've set it up with this you know
rewriting rules for some hypergraph
that's going on underneath that's a very
complicated thing if we were stuck you
know experiencing the world in terms of
this typograph being Rewritten all the
time we wouldn't be able to sort of go
and Lead our lives in a simple ways it's
like you know when you have molecules
and a gas bouncing around if we had to
follow every molecule that would be a
very different thing from our typical
experience of a gas which is just this
sort of continuous fluid so I think the
the thing that
that um uh in we're we're kind of we we
experience it's very important to find
these sort of slices of computational
reducibility because they're the things
that we can build engineering we can
make a predictable life out of and so on
and those are things which again in uh
but but many of those you know the the
many of those pieces of computational
reducibility we haven't yet found we
don't yet have names for as we find them
we may be able to make use of them and
we may be able to kind of uh expand our
experience of of the world
um in a way which which makes use of
those things but I think in um uh and
you know is it the case that sort of uh
we'll be able to use uh well you're
asking kind of for example one one
question you can ask is will there be a
science of machine learning that would
be a reasonable kind of question you
know is it is it going to be the case
you know right now people say well uh
what might a science of machine learning
look like
well that's an interesting question it's
uh the you know when uh here's an
example so typically a machine learning
you you know you do a training you're
finding you know you're finding a
particular path where you get to a a
good point where you have a nice trained
neural Nets imagine you followed all
possible paths it'd be a computationally
absurd you know thing to do but the
universe does something very much like
that in the way that quantum mechanics
Works in physics one of the things
that's taken me a while to get used to
is the idea that the universe is a
profitably waster of computational
resources it's constantly following all
these different Paths of History which
we conflate together when we actually
experience the world but it followed all
these different paths so imagine that
you did that for for machine learning
not necessarily practical at first but
imagine that you could do that and
imagine you could start thinking about
kind of that space of possible path that
were followed imagine you could start
using ideas from physics to think about
that that set of possible paths imagine
you could think about things like you
could think about sort of the formation
of something like Continuum space out of
all of those different possible paths
that might be followed you know there
are there are ways that you could
imagine doing some kind of science where
you start saying well there's an event
horizon that will fall form in this part
of sort of training space things like
this now right now it's it's that might
be something where we would say oh
that's really quite interesting science
it's irrelevant to the practicalities of
machine learning or it might turn out
that understanding things at that level
with that kind of sort of generalization
and then going back to the specifics
might turn out to be really valuable I
don't know yet I think that what we can
say from our experience in understanding
physics and fundamental physics is there
are some very powerful techniques that
one can use that in a sense have already
been discovered in physics that once we
know that physics is computational they
can be applied those things that have
been discovered in physics can be
transported to lots of other areas like
for example machine learning but in
terms of uh you know do I do I expect
that there will be many uh another thing
to say about about architectures of
neural Nets and so on is you know the
principle of computational equivalence
kind of tells you in the end it doesn't
really matter in the end if you kind of
bash it hard enough it's going to be
able to sort of learn quotes learn
anything now there may be when I say
bash it hard enough there might be a
factor of a billion difference in
practice and that makes big difference
in in the world as it is but I think and
the other question is the thing that
we've been sort of Lucky about is that
as I was mentioning before the neural
Nets that we have when they generalize
they generalize in Fairly human ways and
I think we don't fully understand that I
think that's a fact about Neuroscience
as much as it's a fact about machine
learning I don't think that's something
you can't prove that it's not something
where you can get a mathematical proof
this thing is going to generalize in a
human way because it depends how we
humans work and that's something that is
really a matter of natural science of
Neuroscience and so on to determine but
you know there happens to be an
alignment there possibly because the
underlying sort of McCulloch pits level
architecture is quite similar between
our brains and what have happens in
neural Nets and I think
that that's uh so you know that that's a
that's something that has been fortunate
I don't think uh and uh you know I mean
for me you know I first looked at neural
Nets back in 1981 or 1980 and uh you
know they didn't do anything interesting
I couldn't really get them to do
anything I I decided they were way too
complicated to understand scientifically
so I started looking at things like
cellular automata where you just have
these fixed cells that have a very
simple behavior and you don't have the
sort of connection to everything else
and all these weights and so on and uh
turned out that you know I managed to
figure out a very rich set of behaviors
that happen even in this much much much
simpler systems and those kinds of
behaviors certainly will happen even
more so in neural Nets well at least in
the neural Nets as they exist in
something like church EBT are just
essentially these feed forward kind of
networks that that don't um uh that
don't have the possibility of kind of
have having sort of infinite
computations they're just you know just
put in the input and and let it Ripple
forward so to speak but uh but something
in combination with Wolfram Alpha is
what you know yeah yeah right but once
you can do that once once you've got
sort of actual computation in the loop
and the thing that that to to emphasize
perhaps about what I think we're adding
to the world of of kind of large
language models with with both language
and modern Alpha is it's both the depth
of computation the kind of possibility
of irreducible computation and the
structured knowledge of the world that
we actually do have there's a there
there so to speak There's an actual
representation of you know a city a you
know a chemical element a molecule
something like that there's a hard
computational representation of that
it's not well I saw that a few times on
the web and of course that's not how the
neural net actually presents it but you
know it's it's sort of you know
somewhere inside that neural net is some
collection of Weights we don't
understand exactly how but some
collection of Weights that represent the
hundred times that this particular
molecule showed up on on the web
um of course that if you say well what
about the molecule which didn't show up
on the web well the the extrapolation
from what did show up is an
extrapolation based on this kind of
extrapolation that neural Nets do that
humans seem to also do and whether that
is what is the kind of scientific
physical extrapolation who's to say the
thing that has been a you know one of
the surprises was that neural Nets an
even large language models have been
successful in things like protein
folding and that's it's it's a bit
unclear that that's a place where that's
really physics that wasn't just us
talking about things or at least
probably that's the case I mean in in
actuality the way those things tend to
work is they're they're sort of just
making a correspondence with what's been
physically observed to large chunks of
the of the protein and then the big
effort of the machine learning model is
to figure out how to fit together those
sort of physically known chunks so to
speak and how to sort of smooth out the
correspondence between those and it's
sort of I you know I do kind of Wonder
the extent to which the uh sort of
there's the the proteins that well the
proteins that biology happens to use
which is a tiny set of all possible
proteins and sort of what the
correspondence is between kind of what
happens to get used in biology and what
we happen to be thinking about and
representing in human language you know
I think that's the uh you know when it
comes to you were mentioning that the
sort of the um
the kind of what's interesting so to
speak between the the two random and the
two simple and so on and uh you know
biology I think has has also picked out
some particular domain of things and
it's I've been actually a project that I
that I started a depressingly long time
ago when I was a kid
um of trying to understand the second
law of Thermodynamics which is you know
this law of entropy increased the fact
that things always tend to get more
random you know I finally think I
finally sort of understood that and I
finally was writing something about it
and that's when chat GPT came out and
and I started to uh uh to think a bit
about that but but in any case one of
the things that's come out of that
thinking about the second law is that
you know we all know about solids
liquids and gases and so on but when
when you have biological tissue what is
that is it is it a liquid is it a solid
well it's really neither of those things
it's a it's a weird phase of matter that
is kind of a computational phase of
matter where we increasingly know from
molecular biology that biology sort of
explicitly transports molecules around
and sort of quotes meaningful ways they
don't just run around randomly not that
they're really random in a liquid but
they they seem random to us in a liquid
but we can we can already recognize that
there is sort of structure in the way
that things are transported around
inside cells inside molecular biological
processes and it's sort of interesting
the extent to which that in even in the
the sort of that low level of biology
once once again seeing these things
which somehow have this sort of they
read to us as meaningful structure and
exactly how that sort of all fits
together with with what we can sort of
how we understand what we can understand
and so on I don't know how that all
works yet
thank you
wonderful um Dr Wolfram unfortunately
we've come to time this has been an
absolute honor thank you so much for
joining us today we we really appreciate
it lots of interesting questions we
didn't get we didn't get deeply
technical but uh uh this was really
really fun thank you very much